Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
(doctor)
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD
OF IMPETIGO?
IT IS SOMEWHAT
CONTAGIOUS,
BUT IT SHOULD GO AWAY
IN SEVERAL DAYS.
MICHELLE'S SKIN INFECTION
FREAKED OUT HER ROOMMATES...
LLUVY, DID YOU GUYS USE
THE SAME MAKEUP?
AND LLUVY CONTINUED TO
STRUGGLE IN HER PHOTO SHOOT...
IT'S
THE WORST PHOTO
IN THE HISTORY OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
BUT IN PERSON,
NOELLE FAILED
TO LOOK THE PART
OF A MODEL...
THANKS,
NOELLE.
AND WAS
SENT HOME.
TEN GIRLS
REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
IT'S CLEARING UP.
IT SHOULD BE GONE
IN A COUPLE DAYS.
ARE YOU HAPPY?
IS IT A RELIEF
FOR YOU?
OH, YEAH,
DEFINITELY,
AND IT'S NOT
AS CONTAGIOUS.
I MEAN, THERE'S LIKE
A SLIM CHANCE, BUT...
YOU GUYS ARE SAFE,
DON'T WORRY.
NOW YOU CAN RUB YOUR HEAD
ON OUR PILLOWS.
YEP.
I HAVE IMPETIGO,
LIKE A BACTERIAL THING,
BUT THE FACT THAT MY SKIN
IS, LIKE, CLEARING UP
AND EVERYTHING,
AND IT'S GOING AWAY IS
DEFINITELY LIFTING
MY SPIRITS.
PAT, PAT,
RUB, RUB,
PAT, PAT
AND BACK OFF.
LAST ELIMINATION,
OH, SERIOUSLY,
IF I AM THE LAST TWO AGAIN,
I DON'T EVEN WANT
TO THINK ABOUT IT.
LLUVY, THE JUDGES
LOOK AT YOU
AS HAVING
SUCH AMAZING POTENTIAL,
AND THEN YOUR PICTURES
HAVE BEEN,
"WAH-WAH-WAH."
I KNOW I HAVE TO,
YOU KNOW,
STEP IT UP,
LIKE, 110 PERCENT.
TYRA MAIL!
"TOP MODELS NEED
TO HAVE GOOD FIGURES.
"HOW BANKABLE ARE YOU?
"BE READY AT NOON."
"HOW BANKABLE ARE YOU?"
"GOOD FIGURES."
♪♪♪
THE TYRA MAIL
ABOUT BEING BANKABLE,
PEOPLE ARE THINKING THAT
MAYBE IT WAS GONNA BE AN AUCTION
FOR EACH
OF US GIRLS,
LIKE HOW MUCH
WE'RE WORTH.
HELLO, GOOD AFTERNOON,
GIRLS.
BECAUSE OF
OUR CONFIDENTIALITY,
I HAVE A REQUIRED
STANDARD AGREEMENT
THAT MUST BE SIGNED
BY EACH OF YOU.
WHAT IS THIS FOR?
IT'S, UM...
THIS MAN IS
HANDING US CONTRACTS.
HE'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
IT'S JUST A SIMPLE CONTRACT.
WE DON'T HAVE
MUCH TIME.
I'M CONFUSED.
I'M SORRY.
FINISH, PLEASE.
YOU HAVE
TO EITHER SIGN IT
AND GO IN LIKE
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO,
OR IF WE DON'T SIGN IT,
WE GET TO WAIT OUTSIDE,
SO I JUST SIGNED IT.
I JUST
FELT PRESSURE.
WE WERE ALL JUST SO CONFUSED
AND, "WHAT?"
AFTER WE SIGN
OUR CONTRACTS,
WE ARE ESCORTED
INTO THE ROOM.
AAH!
WELCOME TO
BANKABLE PRODUCTIONS.
THIS IS
MY COMPANY.
WELL, TODAY I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE BUSINESS SIDE
OF MODELING.
I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE HAD
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES TAKEN.
YOU'VE LEARNED
HOW TO WALK.
YOU'VE LEARNED HOW
TO PUT ON MAKEUP,
BUT NONE OF THAT
IS WORTH ANYTHING
IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE BUSINESS SIDE
OF THIS INDUSTRY,
AND I WANT
TO INTRODUCE A WOMAN
THAT I WOULD NOT
BE HERE TODAY
IF SHE WERE NOT
IN EXISTENCE.
THIS IS
CAROLINE LONDON.
MY MOTHER.
(squeals)
SHE MANAGED THE FIRST SEVEN
YEARS OF MY CAREER,
SO TODAY WE'RE JUST GONNA TALK
TO YOU GUYS
ABOUT THIS WHOLE BUSINESS
SIDE OF MODELING.
I NEED TO LEARN
ABOUT THAT KIND OF STUFF,
'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW MUCH
OF THE BUSINESS.
I WANT INTRODUCE A GENTLEMAN
THAT YOU GUYS ALREADY MET.
DON BANKS.
THIS IS
MY FATHER.
OH!
GREETINGS, LADIES.
I KNEW IT!
I WANT TO ALSO
BRING IN JOE GUARDARRAMA,
A REALLY GREAT
LAWYER.
THE PAPER THAT
YOU GUYS SIGNED TODAY,
YOU PRETTY MUCH SIGNED
YOUR LIVES AWAY.
I OWN YOU NOW.
YES, MY FATHER DON BANKS
OWNS YOU IN PERPETUITY,
WHICH MEANS FOREVER.
YOU ALSO MUST JUMP
FIVE TIMES
EVERY TIME YOU HEAR
THE WORD "MODEL."
CAN I SEE SOME JUMPING
RIGHT NOW?
EVERY TIME YOU HEAR
THE WORD "MODEL."
MODEL, MODEL,
MODELS ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
EVERYTHING YOU SIGN
IS VERY IMPORTANT,
WHETHER YOU KNOW
WHAT'S IN IT OR NOT.
IF YOU HAVE DOUBTS,
TRUST YOUR INSTINCTS.
DON'T SIGN IT.
ARE, UH, YOU GUYS
GONNA RIP THOSE UP?
(laughs)
NO, THEY ARE PROPERTY
OF BANKABLE PRODUCTIONS.
AND THE LAST SENTENCE
SAYS
THAT THEY'RE VOID, NULL
AND UNENFORCEABLE.
OH!
THEY'RE NOT REAL.
AND IN THIS INDUSTRY,
THERE'S ALWAYS, ON JOBS,
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEBODY TRYING
TO GET YOU TO SIGN SOMETHING.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE HAD SOMEONE
COME UP TO THEM AND SAY,
"OH, MY GOD,
YOU SHOULD BE A MODEL.
"YOU'RE FABULOUS.
AND JUST PAY ME $5,000,
"AND IT'S GREAT."
THIS GUY CAME UP
TO ME.
HE'S LIKE, "OH, YOU'RE GORGEOUS.
YOU SHOULD BE A MODEL."
AND SO I WENT THERE
THE NEXT DAY,
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"JUST PAY US 995 BUCKS."
I JUST HAD A SIMILAR STORY.
THEY WANTED ME TO PAY $2,000
TO TAKE ALL THESE CLASSES,
SO THEY COULD TURN ME
INTO SOMETHING.
IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR YOU ALL TO KNOW
AND FOR ALL YOUNG GIRLS
EVERYWHERE TO UNDERSTAND,
THAT IF AN AGENCY ASKS YOU
FOR ANY TYPE OF MONEY UP FRONT,
IT IS A SCAM.
IN ORDER TO BE
A TOP MODEL,
YOU ALSO HAVE TO BE
A TOP BUSINESSWOMAN.
SURROUND YOURSELF WITH EXPERTS
IN MANY DIFFERENT FIELDS,
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO BE MINDFUL
THAT THEY ARE REPUTABLE.
WHEN I STARTED,
I ALWAYS TOOK THIS INDUSTRY
AS A BUSINESS,
BUT I THINK MY SUCCESS HAS BEEN
SEPARATING WHO I AM
FROM WHAT I DO.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S TYRA,
THAT THING, THAT...
AND THEN THERE'S JUST ME
WITH NO HAIR WEAVE,
MY HAIR NAPPY,
HANGING OUT AT HOME.
ONCE YOU WIN
THIS COMPETITION,
THE WHOLE WORLD'S GONNA BE
LOOKING AT YOU
AND PICKING YOU
APART.
"WHY DID SHE WIN?
I WANTED THE OTHER ONE TO WIN!"
"LOOK AT
HER WALK."
"OH, MY GOD,
HER NOSE IS SO WEIRD."
"DID YOU SEE--
SHE HAS A STOMACH!"
I'M ALWAYS
CRITICIZING MYSELF.
I AM
MY TOUGHEST CRITIC,
AND I KNOW WHAT
I NEED TO WORK ON.
I HAVE TO JUST RELAX
AND BE MYSELF.
BYE!
DON'T SIGN
NOTHING!
IT IS
A BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE
TO BE SMART
AND BE
ON YOUR TOES,
AND YOU ARE
YOUR OWN BUSINESS.
THERE'S A LOT MORE
THAT GOES ON
THAN JUST BEING
A PRETTY FACE.
BEING
IN THE HOUSE,
THE STRESS
WILL GET TO YOU,
AND IT WILL
TEAR YOU DOWN.
DON'T SHOW YOUR BOOTY
ALL THE TIME.
AND JUST TO BE ABLE
TO LAUGH WITH EACH OTHER
AND JUST HAVE
A GOOD TIME
AND FORGET ABOUT ELIMINATIONS
THAT ARE COMING UP.
DO YOU HAVE
MASCARA?
TIFFANY AND I
AND A FEW OF THE GIRLS DECIDED
WE WERE GONNA
HAVE FUN TONIGHT.
WE ARE GONNA, LIKE,
JUST LET GO
AND GO OUT TO DINNER
AND GET DRESSED UP.
LET'S GO,
LADIES!
COME ON!
I'M A CRAZY PERSON.
I CAN GO OUT AND HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NOT ONE DRINK,
AND I WILL BE GOOFY
AND BE CRAZY.
THAT'S
MY PERSONALITY.
THIS IS GONNA
BE FUN.
OH, MY GOD.
I'M TAKING MY SHOES OFF,
SO I CAN SIT.
WE ALL GO IN,
TAKE OUR SHOES OFF,
SIT DOWN ON OUR PILLOWS,
GET COMFORTABLE,
AND THEN SOME GIRLS
START ORDERING DRINKS.
TO PEACE!
WE'RE JUST READY TO CUT LOOSE
AND REALLY HAVE A GOOD TIME.
CHEERS TO BEING
THE LAST TEN STANDING.
TO PEACE.
I WILL DRINK
TO THAT.
I'LL DRINK TO THAT.
BECCA, WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH YOU?
BECCA, ARE YOU
SUCH A FREAKIN' LOSER,
YOU CAN'T HAVE
A DANG DRINK?
BRITTANY'S DRINKING
BOTHERS ME.
YOU CAN DRINK
AND HAVE FUN...
HEY, HEY!
BUT I THINK
ONCE IT GETS TO A POINT
WHERE YOU START
TO LOSE CONTROL,
I THINK THAT'S WHEN
YOU'VE TAKEN IT TOO FAR.
YOU'VE HAD
THREE BAD PHOTOS.
STOP, STOP, STOP!
WE'VE BEEN
IN FOUR PHOTO SHOOTS.
AND I AM
MY HARDEST CRITIC,
BUT ACTUALLY HEARING IT
FROM SOMEBODY ELSE
MADE ME THINK
ABOUT STUFF LIKE THAT.
YEAH, WHITE GIRLS
BE LIKE THIS.
(laughs)
COME HERE,
WHITE GIRL.
♪ GO, WHITE GIRL ♪♪
NO, YOU DO NOT WANT
TO SEE ME DANCE!
♪ GO, WHITE GIRL ♪♪
BRITTANY, YOU KNOW,
DRANK TOO MUCH
AND STARTED
BEING
VERY DISRESPECTFUL
OF THE RESTAURANT.
SO I WAS, LIKE, "OH, GOD,
WE'RE TEARING THIS PLACE APART."
BRITTANY DRANK ABOUT
A BOTTLE OF WINE ON TEQUILA,
AND, UH, SHE WENT
KIND OF CRAZY.
WHOO, I LIKE IT!
I WAS REALLY UPSET,
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT ONLY
REPRESENTING YOURSELF,
BUT YOU'RE REPRESENTING
THE "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
AS A GROUP.
MODELS GONE WILD!
THE WAY
WE WERE REPRESENTED
WAS NOT HOW I WANT PEOPLE
TO SEE ME.
EVERYBODY,
IT WAS SO FUN,
AND I'M
SO GLAD.
THANK YOU ALL.
THE ONLY TWO PEOPLE
I'M GON' SAY WAS NOT FUN
WAS REBECCA
AND KAHLEN.
KAHLEN--
THAT SURPRISED ME,
BECAUSE SHE'S SO, LIKE, FUN,
AND CUTE AND OUTGOING,
AND SHE DIDN'T.
IT WAS A FUN NIGHT!
BRITTANY STARTED
WITH THE BOOTY...
♪ BARTA BARTA BOW ♪♪
I GOT ON
THE TABLE FIRST.
I MEAN, I AM...
WHAT'S UP,
WHAT'S UP?
WHAT'S UP, WHAT'S UP?
HEY,
BRITTANY!
BRITTANY
IS VERY PLAYFUL.
SHE'S VERY FUN
AND OUTGOING,
BUT WHEN
SHE STARTS DRINKING,
SHE GETS REALLY LOOSE
AND SHE, YOU KNOW,
GOES REALLY FAR OUT.
(screaming)
SHE SHOULD BE
MORE PROFESSIONAL
WHEN IT COMES
TO STUFF LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW,
'CAUSE THAT'S GONNA
GET YOU ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
(snoring)
LAST NIGHT
AT ELECTRIC LOTUS,
WHEN PEOPLE STARTED CLEARING
DISHES OFF THE TABLE
AND GLASSES
AND DANCED ON A DINNER TABLE
IN A BEAUTIFUL RESTAURANT,
I WAS BOTHERED
BY THAT.
YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE.
OH, MAN,
LET THERE BE LIGHT!
I LOVE BRITTANY
SO MUCH,
BUT IN SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS,
I AM NOT GOING
TO DRINK A LOT
TO PUT MYSELF
IN A SITUATION
WHERE I COULD HURT MY CHANCES
OF REACHING MY DREAM.
I'M A PRETTY
FUNNY PERSON.
YOU ARE, BUT YOU'RE EVEN
FUNNIER WHEN YOU'RE DRUNK.
THE REAL, TRUE BRITTANY
COMES OUT.
I NEED SOMETHING
TO DRINK.
TYRA MAIL!
"WORKING HARD EACH AND
EVERY DAY WITH NO PLAY?
"NOW IT'S TIME
TO PARTY.
"BE GORGEOUS
AT 2:15 P.M."!
(cheering)
PARTY!
OH!
IT WAS FUNNY
THAT WE GOT
THE TYRA MAIL
SAYING, "NO PLAY"
WHEN WE WERE ALL, LIKE,
HAVING SO MUCH FUN.
I CANNOT STAND YOU PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NO CLASS.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
I WAS JUST THINKING, "GOSH,
WHAT KIND OF PARTY
ARE YOU GONNA GO TO
AT 2:15 IN THE AFTERNOON?"
I'M NOT WEARING
A JACKET.
WHERE'S MY BLACK
JACKET?
WE ALL GO TO FIND
OUR BEST BLACK DRESSES,
AND JUST TRY TO GET,
LIKE, SO CUTE
FOR WHATEVER
WE'RE GETTING READY TO DO.
WE GO WAY UP, LIKE,
IN BEL-AIR SOMEWHERE,
LIKE SOME REALLY NICE AREA
UP IN THE HILLS.
WELL, YOU GUYS ALL LOOK
SO BEAUTIFUL.
LOOK AT YOU!
YOU GUYS ALL LIKE LIKE
YOU HAD A LITTLE MAKEOVER.
SO GUESS WHAT?
COVER GIRL IS GETTING
A MAKEOVER.
THEY'RE ADDING
A TOTALLY NEW LOOK TO THE STORE,
LIKE, NEW PRODUCTS
AND NEW FACES,
AND THEY'RE HAVING A PARTY
AT THIS BEAUTIFUL HOME TONIGHT
TO UNVEIL
THAT NEW LOOK.
SO TRY TO MEET
AND IMPRESS EVERYONE IN THERE.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
ALL RIGHT?
NO TIME
TO BE NERVOUS,
SO LET'S GO INSIDE
AND HAVE SOME FUN.
♪♪♪
HELLO,
HOW ARE YOU?
GOOD,
I'M KIARA.
ONE OF THE ACTUAL
COVER GIRL MODELS, KIARA,
IS AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE STEPS,
AND SHE
WELCOMES ME IN.
WELCOME TO
THE LAUNCH PARTY-- HOW ARE YOU?
REALLY WELL,
I'M KIARA.
THANK YOU--
ENJOY.
NO PROBLEM-- HI!
SO THE GIRLS WERE INVITED
TO A PARTY TONIGHT,
BUT WHAT
THEY DON'T KNOW
IS TONIGHT IS REALLY
A CHALLENGE.
THERE ARE TOP FASHION INSIDERS
FROM "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
"COSMOPOLITAN,"
AND THE COVER GIRL
BRAND
WHO ARE SECRET JUDGES
AT THE CHALLENGE.
WHAT IS YOUR NAME?
I'M EVA.
EVA, NICE TO MEET YOU,
AND WHAT WAS... ?
KIARA.
KIARA, NICE TO MEET YOU,
I'M BRITTANY.
THEY WILL BE
JUDGING THE GIRLS
ON THREE
KEY ELEMENTS--
CONFIDENCE AND POISE...
THAT THING
HAS FALLEN OFF,
LIKE,
FIVE TIMES SO FAR.
HOW THE GIRLS
WORK THE ROOM
AND INTERACT
WITH OTHER PEOPLE...
COVER GIRL HAS SO MUCH,
YOU KNOW,
EVERYTHING'S
SO NATURAL.
NATURAL.
(Jay)
AND HOW WELL THEIR BEAUTY
TRULY SHINES INSIDE AND OUT.
IT'S LIKE, EVER SINCE
I WAS A LITTLE GIRL,
I POSED
ALL THE TIME.
I WAS ALWAYS
POSING.
DRESSING UP?
YEAH.
I WAS, LIKE, 4 YEARS OLD
AND, LIKE, GOING...
I DON'T REALLY WEAR
TOO MUCH MAKEUP,
BUT I CAN WEAR AS MUCH
COVER GIRL AS I WANT
AND STILL
LOOK NATURAL.
I WAS REALLY FOCUSING
ON MYSELF AND MAKING SURE
I LEFT A GOOD IMPRESSION
ON AS MANY PEOPLE AS I COULD.
I'VE NEVER BEEN TO,
LIKE, A BIG PARTY
LIKE THIS
BEFORE, SO...
I'VE BEEN WITH MY FRIENDS
AND STUFF,
BUT THAT'S ABOUT IT.
HOW IS IT TO BE THE CENTER
OF ATTENTION?
IT HUMBLES ME.
GREAT ANSWER.
THAT IS
A GREAT ATTITUDE.
YEAH.
THIS PARTY IS FOR
MEETING PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY.
THERE'S PEOPLE
FROM MAGAZINES.
I WANT TO TRY ONE
OF THOSE THINGS.
"ELLE" MAGAZINE,
"COSMOPOLITAN."
NO, THAT'S THE DRINK
I HAD.
OKAY,
I WANT ONE OF THOSE.
ALL RIGHT,
DOUBLE DISSIN'.
I THINK BRITTANY'S
BEAUTIFUL,
BUT I THINK SOMETIMES
BRITTANY'S PERSONALITY
MAY BE TOO LOUD
AND TOO FORCEFUL.
ALL RIGHT,
HOLD ON.
DRINKS!
(snapping fingers)
THIS IS
A MODELING COMPETITION,
NOT A "WHO'S THE LOUDEST
CHICK" COMPETITION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THE COVER GIRL SPOKESMODELS?
DO YOU HAVE
A FAVORITE ONE?
I DON'T KNOW SOME
OF THE NEW GIRLS, ACTUALLY,
LIKE I DON'T KNOW
WHO SHE IS.
UH-HUH.
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE,
BUT...
YOU JUST MET HER
WHEN YOU CAME IN.
HI, WELCOME TO
THE LAUNCH PARTY.
HOW ARE YOU?
REALLY WELL--
I'M KIARA.
OKAY, WELL,
I JUST LOST POINTS ON THAT ONE.
THIS ALL-DAY LIP COLOR,
I LOVE THIS.
THE ONLY THING IS
WHEN YOUR LITTLE SISTER DRAWS
ON YOUR FACE WITH THAT,
IT DOESN'T...
IT'S NOT
SO GREAT.
YEAH, IT STAYS ON
FOR A PRETTY LONG TIME.
DO YOU SEE YOURSELF AS LIKE,
THE NEXT ONE ON THE WALL?
I THINK MY SPOT WOULD BE
OVER ON THAT WALL.
I DON'T REALLY TRUST
FIRST IMPRESSIONS,
BUT WHEN YOU'RE
A MODEL,
IT'S, LIKE, SO IMPORTANT, LIKE,
TO HAVE SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
DO YOU HAVE, LIKE,
A FAVORITE MAGAZINE?
I LIKE "ELLE."
I LIKE, THE,
YOU KNOW, MAGAZINE.
I'M REALLY NERVOUS
RIGHT NOW,
SO, I'M LOOKING
AT THE MAKEUP,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THE MAKEUP
CAN'T TALK BACK TO ME,
AND IT CAN'T
INTIMIDATE ME.
UH, WHAT'S YOUR NAME
AGAIN?
KERRY.
KERRY, OKAY.
I AM MYSELF
ALL THE TIME.
I'M JUST
A GOOFBALL.
I'M A BIG MASCARA
GIRL.
ARE YOU?
YOU LOOK LIKE
A BIG LASH GIRL.
YEAH.
AND THOSE HAVE
TO BE FAKE.
THEY'RE MINE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE,
IF THESE PEOPLE LIKE YOU,
THEN THESE PEOPLE
LIKE YOU,
BUT IF THEY DON'T,
IT'S GONNA BE KIND OF WEIRD.
EVA-- I HAVEN'T
MET YOU YET.
OH, MY NAME'S
MICHELLE.
I'M DEFINITELY WORRIED
WITH THE WHOLE SKIN ASPECT.
IT'S KIND OF
CLEARING UP,
AND I ALWAYS TRY TO FIND
THE POSITIVE SIDE OF THINGS.
I MEAN, THE NEGATIVE SIDE'S
NOT GONNA GET YOU ANYWHERE.
FOR A MODEL, THE SKIN
IS THE CANVAS, BASICALLY.
ESPECIALLY FOR A BEAUTY CAMPAIGN
SUCH AS COVER GIRL,
YOU NEED TO HAVE
FLAWLESS SKIN.
VERY NICE
MEETING YOU ALL.
NICE
TO MEET YOU.
COVER GIRLS ARE MUCH MORE
THAN JUST PRETTY FACES.
TONIGHT'S EVENT WAS ABOUT
LETTING YOUR INNER BEAUTY SHINE
WHILE INTERACTING
WITH KEY EDITORS
AND OTHER INFLUENTIAL
PEOPLE.
WHAT YOU
DIDN'T KNOW WAS
ACTUALLY TONIGHT
WAS A CHALLENGE.
LOOK
AT TATIANA.
YEAH,
I FIGURED IT OUT.
THERE WERE JUDGES MIXED IN
WITH THE GUESTS AT THE PARTY.
WHAT?
NOW I HAVE NOTES
ON EVERYBODY.
TIFFANY, THE JUDGES FELT THAT
YOU WERE GLUED TO THE PRODUCT,
AND THEY WANTED TO GET
TO KNOW YOU.
KAHLEN, YOU HAD A GREAT LOOK
AND SKIN.
NAIMA, YOU WERE A BIT
TOO QUIET AND RESERVED.
KEENYAH, THEY ACTUALLY THOUGHT
YOU WERE VERY POISED
AND THAT YOU WOULD ROCK
ANY INDUSTRY PARTY.
CHRISTINA, YOU WEREN'T
PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU MET.
TATIANA,
THE JUDGES FELT LIKE
THEY COULDN'T GET ANYTHING
OUT OF YOU AT ALL.
LLUVY, YOU WERE
VERY ELOQUENT
AND KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
YOUR UNIQUE BEAUTY.
REBECCA, THEY THOUGHT
YOU HAD A GREAT BODY,
AND YOU WERE
BEAUTIFUL.
BRITTANY, THEY WERE
A LITTLE CONCERNED.
THEY THOUGHT YOUR PRIORITY WAS
MORE ABOUT YOUR DRINKING
THAN MEETING EVERYBODY
AT THE PARTY.
MICHELLE, THEY FELT THAT
YOU DIDN'T LOOK COMFORTABLE
AND THAT YOUR SKIRT
WAS TOO SHORT.
WITH THAT, THE WINNER
OF TONIGHT'S CHALLENGE
GETS TO PICK
ONE FRIEND,
AND YOU GUYS GET TO SPEND
AN AMAZING NIGHT
AT A FABULOUS HOTEL
ON THE BEACH.
SO THE JUDGES HAD
TO CHOOSE SOMEONE,
AND WHO THEY FEEL
MOST EXEMPLIFIED A COVER GIRL
AT TONIGHT'S EVENT...
WAS KEENYAH.
COME UP HERE.
AND I'M LIKE,
"ARE YOU SERIOUS?"
BECAUSE THIS WHOLE TIME,
I NEVER WIN.
SO WHO ARE YOU GONNA PICK
TO GO TO YOUR EVENT TONIGHT?
I'M GONNA PICK
BRITTANY.
(squeals)
I DON'T KNOW IF KEENYAH'S
LOOKING FOR THIS BIG SISTER,
BUT BRITTANY AND KEENYAH
NEED TO STICK TOGETHER.
THEY NEED
TO GET CUT TOGETHER.
DON'T FOCUS ON THE BOOZE
SO MUCH!
I WASN'T!
YOU GOTTA FOCUS
ON THE PEOPLE!
YOU GUYS HAVE
A GOOD TIME TONIGHT,
AND I'LL SEE
YOU GUYS LATER.
♪♪♪
PLUSH BEDS.
AND WE WON'T BE GETTING IN
FOR HOURS.
(laughs)
WHAT'S GOING ON
IN HERE?
WE WALK INSIDE,
AND THERE'S, LIKE,
THIS HUGE TRAY FULL OF DESSERTS
AND ALL THE V.I.P. TREATMENT
TYPE STUFF.
AND WE'RE LIKE,
"WHOA, THIS IS, LIKE, CRAZY."
(laughs)
YOUR BUTT.
MY BUTT!
HEY, TYRA MAIL!
♪ TYRA MAIL ♪♪
"THE COMPETITION'S
GETTING TOUGHER.
"ARE YOU RUNNING
OUT OF GAS?
"BE READY AT 6:30
IN THE MORNING."
WHO HAS GAS?
"ARE YOU RUNNING
OUT OF GAS?"
I HOPE WE AIN'T GOT TO PUSH
NO DAMN CARS NOWHERE.
THIS LOOKS GOOD.
THIS IS
REALLY GOOD.
WHAT DO WE
GOT HERE?
YOU SHOULD
READ IT.
"CONGRATULATIONS.
"ENJOY YOUR V.I.P.
SURROUNDINGS.
"AS AN ADDED BONUS
TO YOUR WIN,
"YOU HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
SHOWING UP FASHIONABLY LATE."
LATE TO WHERE?
WE GET TO BE FASHIONABLY LATE,
WHICH IS GREAT,
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO WAKE UP
SO EARLY EVERY MORNING.
THIS IS A TOAST TO MY VERY BEST
FRIEND IN THE HOUSE, KEENYAH!
I GIVE HER A TOAST
FOR PICKING ME, HER BEST FRIEND.
I FEEL CLOSE
TO EVERYBODY,
BUT YET, LIKE, IT'S
REALLY LONELY AT TIMES, TOO.
SO HOW ARE YOU?
NOT GOOD.
WHY, WHAT'S WRONG?
THIS IS
SO STUPID.
I KNOW I DON'T LOOK LIKE
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
I DON'T THINK
I'M BEAUTIFUL.
I JUST THINK
I'M WEIRD-LOOKING.
I'M DIFFERENT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO CHANGE
WHO YOU ARE.
I JUST WANT
MY PUPPY.
I LOVE YOU.
I'M JUST
COMPLETELY LOST,
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON
IN GOD'S LITTLE PLAN
UP THERE.
BYE, BABY, BYE.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING
I CAN KEEP THINKING ABOUT
IS TYRA TELLING US PEOPLE ARE
GONNA JUDGE YOU RIGHT OFFHAND
AND MAKE COMMENTS THAT
YOU'RE NOT GONNA WANT TO HEAR,
AND THEY'RE GONNA
CRITIQUE YOU.
BUT IT'S LIKE, YOU HAVE
TO BRUSH THAT STUFF OFF
AND KNOW
WHO YOU ARE.
BUT SO, I HAD A LOT OF
GOOD COMMENTS AT THE PARTY,
WHICH WAS REALLY
HELPFUL TO ME,
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN FEELING
VERY, LIKE, IN THE MIDDLE.
TOMORROW,
6:30
IN THE MORNING.
ARE YOU GUYS RUNNING OUT
OF GAS?
LIKE, THE PICTURES ARE
A BIG CHUNK OF WHAT MAKES US
GO HOME OR NOT,
AND THAT'S
MY BIGGEST FAULT,
SO I REALLY NEED TO WORK
110 PERCENT ON MY PICTURES,
'CAUSE IF NOT,
THEN I'M GONNA BE
GOING HOME.
♪♪♪
HAVE YOU EVER WOKEN UP--
AND THIS HAPPENS AT HOME
ALL THE TIME--
AND LIKE
YOUR INSIDES HURT?
NO.
WE RECEIVED
TYRA MAIL.
IT SAID, "ARE YOU RUNNING
OUT OF GAS?
"BE READY AT 6:15."
KEENYAH ACTUALLY WON
THE COMPETITION,
OF COURSE, WAS GONNA PICK
BRITTANY TO GO TO, LIKE,
THE BEACHFRONT HOTEL
WITH HER.
IT WAS REALLY GREAT
TO SEE THEM WIN,
BECAUSE
THEY HAVEN'T YET.
ROOM SERVICE.
GOOD MORNING.
AS A BONUS OF OUR WIN,
WE GET TO BE FASHIONABLY LATE.
BREAKFAST
IN BED.
IT WAS
WONDERFUL.
WE GOT TO SPEND
THE NIGHT
AND JUST BE TREATED
LIKE ROYALTY, LIKE CELEBRITIES,
WHICH WE SOON
WILL BE, HOPEFULLY.
TO BREAKFAST
IN BED
AND MAY THERE BE
MANY MORE.
YEAH!
♪♪♪
WE'RE, LIKE,
IN THE BOONIES,
DRIVING, LIKE,
BY A BUNCH
OF JOSHUA TREES.
♪♪♪
WE'RE THINKING WE'RE GONNA BE
IN MOTORCYCLES AND RACE CARS.
WE ROLL UP TO
A DESERTED GAS STATION.
WELL, THANKS FOR STOPPING BY
TO PICK ME UP
ON MY LITTLE
HITCHHIKE.
WE'RE HERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE DESERT.
NOW IN THE DESERT,
OF COURSE,
IT'S GONNA GET VERY HOT
AS THE DAY GOES ALONG,
BUT THESE AREN'T
THE ONLY ELEMENTS
YOU'RE GONNA
BE DEALING WITH TODAY.
OH!
OH, MY GOD!
YOU GUYS CAN
OBVIOUSLY SEE
YOU'VE GOT WIND,
UP TO GALE-FORCE WINDS HERE
YOU GOTTA DEAL WITH.
THE SAME WITH
THIS TORRENTIAL RAIN.
ALL OF THESE ELEMENTS COMBINED
ARE GONNA ADD UP
FOR A HOT,
SULTRY SHOOT.
NOW THE ACTUAL LOOK
FOR TODAY'S SHOOT IS,
WE'RE AT THIS GAS STATION OUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DESERT, RIGHT?
SO YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA BE
THESE SEXY, HOT MECHANICS
ALL GREASED UP,
DEALING WITH THE ELEMENTS.
I'M GONNA BE, LIKE, SCREAMING
FROM BEYOND THE RAIN BARRIER,
'CAUSE I'M NOT GETTING
IN THE RAIN.
NOW TODAY'S
PHOTOGRAPHER
IS SOMEONE WHO'S ACTUALLY
VERY ACCOMPLISHED
AS A PHOTOGRAPHER,
BUT YOU MAY NOT
KNOW WHO.
NO!
THAT'S RIGHT.
OUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY
IS MATHU,
WHO'S BEEN DOING
OUR MAKEUP.
MATHU'S ACTUALLY A VERY
ACCOMPLISHED PHOTOGRAPHER
WHO HAS SHOT
LOTS OF CELEBRITIES,
AND HE IS
SUPER-TALENTED.
♪♪♪
AFTER BREAKFAST,
WE WERE TAKEN TO THE SPA.
WE BOTH GOT
MASSAGES,
DEEP TISSUE MASSAGES THAT
WERE SO GOOD, SO WONDERFUL,
THE BEST MASSAGE I'VE EVER HAD
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
IT WAS AMAZING.
(wind machine starts)
TODAY'S PHOTO SHOOT IS
ABOUT US BEING SEXY
WHILE GETTING BLOWN AWAY
BY HEAVY WIND AND WATER.
IT'S CRAZY.
♪♪♪
KAHLEN, YOU'RE FIRST,
AND WE GOTTA MAKE THIS WORK.
OKAY.
IT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF RAIN, A LITTLE BIT OF WIND.
PLAY WITH IT,
GET INTO IT.
OKAY.
IT'S ALL
ABOUT YOU.
TO MAKE THE SHOT
EVEN MORE DYNAMIC,
I DECIDED TO PUT A SECOND GIRL
IN THE BACKGROUND.
LET'S GET THIS PARTY
STARTED.
THESE PHOTO SHOOTS THAT WE'RE
DOING ARE A LITTLE EXTREME,
BUT AT
THE SAME TIME,
I'M SURE THAT STUFF LIKE THIS
HAPPENS IN THE FASHION WORLD,
JUST PROBABLY
NOT EVERY WEEK.
WHEN IT COMES
TO JUST POSING,
THAT'S SOMETHING
I'M GOOD AT.
MORE MOVEMENT!
I'M WATCHING
THE GIRL BEHIND ME,
'CAUSE I'M LIKE, "DAMN, PLEASE,
YOU WANT TO SWITCH ME?"
♪♪♪
THE WATER
WAS JUST SO COLD,
AND I WAS JUST,
LIKE, IN SHOCK.
AT FIRST,
I COULDN'T BREATHE.
I WAS LIKE,
"OH!"
AND YOU CAN'T HEAR
ANY DIRECTION.
NO, COME FORWARD.
YEAH.
TIFFANY GOT
A LITTLE BIT DISTRACTED
BY ALL THE GOINGS ON,
BUT SHE ACTUALLY
NAILED IT.
SHE REALLY WENT
FOR VERY STRONG POSES.
IT'S REALLY HARD
TO BE SEXY
WITH WINDS BLOWING,
ABOUT TO KNOCK ME DOWN
AND WATER POPPING ME
IN THE EYE, MOUTH AND NOSE.
GOOD JOB,
TIFFANY.
CAN WE GET
ANOTHER GIRL!
CHRISTINA, YOU CAN
WORK YOUR TIRE
BACKWARDS AND FORWARDS
AND WEAR IT OUT.
I FEEL LIKE
I'M WORKING THE TIRE.
I MEAN,
I'M ALL GREASED UP,
YOU KNOW,
THIS SEXY MECHANIC.
♪♪♪
I'VE NEVER BEEN
TO CALIFORNIA BEFORE,
SO I WANTED TO CHECK OUT
THE BEACH.
COME ON!
BRITTANY
WAS TOTALLY EXCITED.
WE WERE
IN THE WATER
PLAYING AROUND LIKE
WE WERE 5 YEARS OLD,
AND WE HAD
A BALL.
WHOO!
MICHELLE, THIS IS NO TIME
TO BE TIMID.
BUT SHE PROMISED ENERGY.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT SHE'S DOING.
ENERGY, LAUGH,
DO STUFF!
GIVE ME SOMETHING!
WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE ENERGY?
THIS WAS YOU.
YOU REALLY GOTTA WORK
ON THAT ENERGY THING.
AND I FELT LIKE MICHELLE
WAS GONNA START TO CRY,
BUT YOU GOTTA
BE HONEST,
BECAUSE THE GIRLS HAVE TO LEARN
FROM THEIR MISTAKES,
BUT WE GOT ONE SHOT
ON MICHELLE.
I THOUGHT I WAS DOING
A PRETTY GOOD JOB,
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
THEY'RE MAKING ME
WORRY.
ALL RIGHT,
SO, NAIMA,
WORK THIS LITTLE BIT
OF THE DOOR.
GET BACK UP,
GIVE US MORE BODY.
IN ORDER FOR ME TO WORK
THE BEST THAT I CAN,
I HAVE TO PUT THIS COMPETITION
ALMOST OUT OF MY HEAD,
FOCUS ON MYSELF,
MY CHARACTER.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
BRAVO.
REALLY GOOD JOB,
GREAT JOB.
GOOD VARIATION.
WE'VE GOT A LOT
TO CHOOSE FROM.
TYRA'S MAIL HAD SAID
THE COMPETITION IS
GETTING TOUGHER,
AND THIS IS
ANOTHER HUGE CHALLENGE FOR ME.
I'M REALLY NERVOUS.
I HOPE I DON'T
CRASH AND BURN.
SHE STILL HAS THAT "REBECCA
OF SUNNYBROOK FARM" THING
GOING ON.
REBECCA
IS SAFE SEX.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHERE I STAND RIGHT NOW.
I THINK IF I DIDN'T NAIL
THAT SHOOT,
THAT THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE
THAT I COULD BE GOING HOME.
YOU NEED TO WORK ON
YOUR SEXUALITY
AND BEING
MORE EDGY.
YES!
TATIANA, YES!
WHEN I THINK OF CARS
AND GASOLINE,
IT IS SOMETHING
I'M INTERESTED IN,
BECAUSE I USED TO WORK ON CARS
A LOT.
YOU SO SURPRISED ME.
(squeals)
I REALLY THINK
THIS IS YOUR BEST SHOOT.
HEY, LLUVY, DON'T BE AFRAID
TO ACT THIS.
LIKE, WE'RE ASKING
SOME OF THE GIRLS
TO GIVE US LIKE,
"AAH!"
LIKE, WE'RE,
LIKE, SCREAMING,
AND THEY'RE
DOING THIS.
THE MORE ENERGY
YOU HAVE,
THE BETTER WE CAN WORK
WITH IT,
IF WE HAVE TO COME IN THERE
AND ELECTRIC CATTLE-PROD YOU.
MAKE IT TALLER!
THERE YOU GO.
LLUVY, SMILE!
BE PLAYFUL!
SMILE, LAUGH!
THERE YOU GO.
PUT THAT LEG DOWN!
SHE'S DOWN
ON THE GROUND.
HEY, LLUVY,
THAT WAS, UM...
THAT WAS
INTERESTING.
SHE WAS, LIKE, SITTING THERE
LIKE THIS.
I'M LIKE, "LLUVY,
DOES THAT FEEL PRETTY?"
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T
LOOK PRETTY.
DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE SEXY?
NO,
I CAN'T.
WHEN I'M TOLD
TO BE SEXY,
I JUST LAUGH 'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT IS.
HOW DO YOU EXPECT TO MODEL
IF YOU DON'T THINK YOU'RE SEXY?
I KNOW.
THAT'S WHAT
I NEED HELP WITH.
I THINK THERE'S GONNA BE
A GOOD SHOT IN THERE, HOPEFULLY.
♪♪♪
HOWDY.
HEY, YOU GUYS ARE
RIGHT ON TIME.
YOUR ASS IS GONNA
FREEZE TO DEATH.
IT'S NOT EASY
AT ALL.
WE FINALLY SHOWED UP
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND EVERYBODY WAS TIRED
AND EXHAUSTED
AND MAD
ABOUT THE SHOOT,
AND WE WERE LIKE, "HEY."
YOU KNOW,
WE WERE ALL RELAXED.
KEENYAH DID
A GOOD JOB,
BUT SHE WENT
TOO FAST.
SHE KIND OF JUST DID IT AND WENT
AND WENT AND WENT AND WENT,
AND SHE FORGETS
THIS IS
A STILL SHOOT,
SO THE PHOTOGRAPHER STILL HAS
TO CAPTURE THE MOMENT.
I NEED YOU TO BELIEVE
YOUR ENVIRONMENT AND ACT IN IT.
I DIDN'T WANT
TO OVERDO IT.
I ALREADY HAVE WHAT THEY CALL,
LIKE, "TOO MUCH SEX APPEAL,"
SO I DIDN'T WANT TO DO ANY POSES
THAT LOOKED TRIPLE "X."
SHE WAS VERY REMINISCENT
OF THE EARLY JANICE DICKINSON
WHEN SHE WAS SITTING ON THE BACK
OF THE TRUCK
AND WHIPPING
HER HAIR BACK.
IT'S DEFINITELY
MY FAVORITE SHOOT SO FAR.
I FEEL PRETTY CONFIDENT
THAT I GOT MY SHOT.
TYRA MAIL!
HOLD ON!
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY NINE OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
"AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
"ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
I THINK THAT
THIS IS GONNA BE
ONE OF THE HARDEST JUDGINGS
SO FAR,
AND LLUVY'S BEEN UP THERE
AND ALMOST BEEN CUT TWICE.
THIS JUST FEELS LIKE DEJA VU
FROM LAST WEEK.
AND I DON'T THINK MICHELLE
HAS GOT WHAT IT TAKES
TO BECOME
A TOP MODEL.
I'M DEFINITELY WORRIED
THAT I'M GONNA GET ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
SO THIS WEEK
YOU LEARNED
ALL ABOUT THE BUSINESS SIDE
OF MODELING,
BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO GET DOWN
TO REAL BUSINESS,
BECAUSE TONIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE OUR FIFTH CUT.
MM!
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
NOW YOU GUYS KNOW ABOUT
OUR AMAZING PRIZES,
THE FIRST BEING
A CONTRACT
WITH THE TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING MANAGEMENT AGENCY--
FORD MODELS--
A SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER, GILLES BENSIMON,
AND $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
THE FIRST JUDGE,
JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS ONE OF
THE WORLD'S FIRST SUPERMODELS.
NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLE MARIN, A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
AND OUR GORGEOUS
SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE,
MATHU ANDERSON.
MATHU'S A LEGENDARY
MAKEUP ARTIST AND PHOTOGRAPHER.
THIS WEEK YOU WILL BE EVALUATED
ON HOW WELL YOU SELL
YOUR MOST IMPORTANT PRODUCT--
BEING WHAT?
YOURSELF.
THAT'S ALL
I'M GONNA SAY.
♪♪♪
"INSIDE THIS BAG YOU WILL
FIND ALL THE MATERIALS NECESSARY
TO CREATE THE PACKAGING
FOR A PERFUME
THAT REPRESENTS
WHO YOU ARE
AS A PERSON
AND AS A MODEL."
WE HAVE TO DECORATE
THE PERFUME BOTTLE
IN FIVE MINUTES,
AND ONE MINUTE
TO EXPLAIN OUR PERFUME
AND KIND OF GIVE
A DESCRIPTION ABOUT IT.
♪♪♪
WHAT?
♪♪
OH, MY GOSH.
ALL RIGHT, KEENYAH,
COME ON DOWN.
THE JUDGES WILL TAKE ON
FIVE DIFFERENT CHARACTERS
FROM AROUND THE GLOBE,
WHICH WILL REPRESENT
CONSUMERS THAT ARE CURIOUS
ABOUT YOUR PRODUCT.
FIRST WE HAVE...
(New York accent)
BABS FIRESTEIN.
(French accent) NOLE LE PUE
FROM FRANCE.
I'M JOHNNY HOTT.
(Russian accent)
IGOR SLUTSKY.
MY-MY-MY NAME
PRECIOUS TANG.
(laughs)
I AM A GIRL WHO REPRESENTS
A LITTLE BIT OF EVERYBODY.
YOU CAN TAKE
THIS FRAGRANCE,
AND YOU CAN DO WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO IT,
AND I AM KEENYAH.
I AM SOMETHING THAT EVERYONE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE TAKEN AROUND.
IF YOU WANT
A CLEAN, FRESH SMELL
THAT WILL LEAVE YOU
BREATHLESS,
AND IT'LL MAKE YOU FEEL GOOD
ALL DAY.
CLOROX
WILL DO THAT.
YOU KNOW, RAID BUG SPRAY
IS MORE SEXY.
YOU TELL ME
WHY YOU SO COLD.
I AM KAHLEN,
AND THIS IS MY FRAGRANCE.
I WENT WITH SOMETHING
A LITTLE MORE NATURAL,
A LITTLE--
YOU ARE BORING ME--
WHAT'S UNIQUE?
EVERY FRAGRANCE HAS
ITS OWN SENSE OF SMELL.
THIS ONE IS--
KAHLEN, HOW WOULD YOUR SCENT
LEAVE YOU FEELING?
IT'S A PERFUME THAT GOES
TO THE INDIVIDUAL,
WHETHER YOU'RE A WORKING MOTHER,
A YOUNG GIRL,
OR EVEN
A JANITOR.
I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IS TIFFANY--
IT IS A CLASSIC,
BEAUTIFUL SCENT
WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF FRUIT TO IT.
NOW YOU SAID
IT'S FRUITY NOW?
FRUITY JUST MEANS LIGHT
AND CITRUSY AND AIRY.
OH, LIKE ON
MY LEMON TREE?
NO!
ORANGES?
IT'S...
NOT EXPENSIVE,
AND IT'S GOT A GOOD LOOK
TO THE BOTTLE.
AND THAT'S IT?
I AM A WRESTLER,
BUT I TRY MY HARDEST
TO BE AS FEMIN--
AS FEM--
I CAN'T TALK.
I TRY TO BE
AS FEMINMINT,
AS FEMIN--
SKIP THAT WORD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT
THROUGH DIFFERENT ANGLES,
IT'S BEAUTIFUL AND SIMPLE,
BUT ELEGANT.
I SEEN A COMMERCIAL
FOR BRITNEY SPEARS.
SHE IN
THE BED.
SHE ROLLIN' AROUND
WITH A BOY.
I FEEL IT,
I WANNA BE HER.
I WANT YOU TO BE
MORE LIKE BRITNEY SPEARS,
YOU KNOW,
HOW SHE DO THE STUFF,
YOU KNOW, LIKE,
SELL IT TO ME.
MY PRODUCT TODAY IS CALLED
"DELICIOUSLY TACKY".
IT'S FOR A MAN
AND A WOMAN.
SO IT'S LIKE RECIPE
FOR BISEXUALISM.
NO, NO, NO, I WANT TO SEE
THE DELICIOUSLY TACKY DANCE NOW.
THE DELICIOUSLY TACKY DANCE
GOES A LITTLE BIT LIKE THIS.
♪ DELICIOUSLY TACKY ♪
♪ DELICIOUSLY ♪♪
OOH, DA!
TACKY, YEAH!
YOU GOTTA GO!
GIT ON OUT,
GIT ON OUT.
ALL RIGHT,
BRITTANY,
SO YOU HAD A PARTY
THAT YOU HAD TO ATTEND.
THEY FELT THAT YOU WANTED TO
DRINK MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
THAT WASN'T IT
AT ALL.
I MADE A JOKE WITH
THE COVER GIRL MODEL.
SHE WAS LIKE,
"THOSE ARE GOOD."
I WAS LIKE, "OH, I'LL TRY
ONE OF THOSE NEXT."
BUT YOU UNDERSTAND
WHO THE CLIENT IS, COVER GIRL?
THERE'S CERTAIN CLIENTS
WHERE YOU CAN BE RAMBUNCTIOUS,
YOU CAN BE CRAZY.
COVER GIRL IS FUN,
BUT IT'S ALSO VERY PROFESSIONAL.
BRITTANY, YOU HAD
TO SELL A FRAGRANCE.
YOUR NEGATIVE,
YOU'RE A FOOL.
YOUR POSITIVE IS,
SO YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT.
PERFECT
PHOTOGRAPH.
AND THE RAIN HAS YOU
A LITTLE DISTORTED,
BUT I STILL FEEL
THE ENERGY,
AND I STILL THINK
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
NEXT IS KAHLEN.
I THOUGHT YOU ROLLED WITH
THE CRAZY PUNCHES VERY WELL.
THANK YOU.
HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
OH, MY GOSH.
MMM,
WORK IT OUT!
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
YOU'VE GOT
A KICK-ASS BODY.
SHE'S LIKE A BOND GIRL.
GIRL, I'D BE PUMPING GAS
AT THAT STATION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, UP NEXT
WE HAVE CHRISTINA.
SO YOU HAD
TO SELL A PERFUME.
IT WAS COLD.
IT WAS
CLINICAL.
IT'S UNIQUE.
IT SETS YOU, UM, APART
FROM EVERYONE ELSE.
YOU HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA
WHO YOU ARE.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING
RIGHT NOW, CHRISTINA?
I'VE SEEN
SO MANY TIMES,
LIKE, MY MOM
GET WALKED ALL OVER,
AND I JUST DON'T WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN TO ME,
ESPECIALLY
IN AN INDUSTRY
THAT CAN EAT YOU UP
AND SPIT YOU OUT.
I'VE LEARNED
TO BE VERY STRONG,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO TELL THE WHOLE WORLD,
BECAUSE THEN THEY JUST
WON'T LIKE YOU,
AND YOU WON'T
GET THE JOB.
I'M SORRY
YOU FEEL BAD.
YOU HAD A SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
SEXY PICTURE.
THAT LOOKS LIKE YOU REALLY
WERE BEARING THE ELEMENTS.
YOU LOOK
LIKE WONDER WOMAN,
LYNDA CARTER.
ALL RIGHT,
TATIANA.
WHAT ON EARTH
HAPPENED?
YOU JUST GAVE UP
BEFORE YOU BEGAN.
I WAS CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT
I WAS SUPPOSED TO BE DOING.
YOU LEFT ME
FEELING CONFUSED.
WOW,
BEAUTIFUL PHOTOGRAPH.
YOU WERE THE ONLY GIRL
TO UNDERSTAND THE HEAD FLIP.
YOU HAVE
SUCH A BEAUTIFUL FACE.
ALL RIGHT, TATIANA,
THANKS.
TIFFANY.
YOU WERE DORKY
AND KIND OF NONCONSEQUENTIAL.
AND HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
TIFFANY, TIFFANY,
TIFFANY,
THIS IS A SHOT WHICH HAS
SHOW MUCH GOING ON IN IT.
YOU KNOW, YOUR FACE HAS
TO OWN THE PICTURE.
IT'S ALSO
A CLASSIC REASON
WHY YOU DON'T GET TATTOOS
ON YOUR CHEST LIKE THIS, PLEASE!
A LOT OF THE SHOTS,
THEY LOOK VERY STRIPPERISH.
NAIMA, YOU DEALT WITH
THE CRAZY PEOPLE SO WELL.
YOU GOT CRAZY PEOPLE
IN YOUR FAMILY?
NO COMMENT.
HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
OH, THAT'S HOT.
YOU WERE AMAZING
TO SHOOT.
IT LOOKS
A LITTLE CROTCHY.
A LITTLE TOO
LEG SPREAD,
AND IT'S
A LITTLE TOO--
I LIKE IT,
IT'S FABULOUS.
I DON'T
LIKE IT.
ALL RIGHTY,
KEENYAH.
YOU WERE SWEET,
YOU WERE CHARMING.
YOU WERE CUTE.
OKAY, NOW LET'S TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S YOUR VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
YOU'VE EVER DONE.
YOUR FACE IS BEAUTIFUL,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOUR FACE IS ALWAYS
GONNA BE BEAUTIFUL,
SO ACTUALLY I THINK
IT'S VERY DISAPPOINTING.
ALL RIGHT,
REBECCA.
REBECCA, I HAVE DOWN THAT YOU
WERE LIKE A GIRL SCOUT COOKIE.
YOU WERE TRYING TO SELL
TO EVERYONE.
I THINK
YOU SOUNDED REHEARSED.
SO YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT.
MMM,
THAT'S CUTE.
LOOK AT THE SWAY
OF THE BACK AND THE BOOTY.
GREAT
BODY POSITION,
BUT IT'S THE FACE,
IT PULLS AN UNCOMFORTABLE,
SORT OF AWKWARD SULK.
YOU DO THIS.
YOU NEED TO...
ALL RIGHT,
LLUVY,
SO YOU HAD TO PITCH
YOUR FRAGRANCE AS A SPOKESMODEL.
LLUVY, YOU WERE
A BUBBLING FOOL.
(sputters)
I FELT LIKE
YOU WERE SO UNSURE.
LLUVY, YOUR EYES AGAIN
ARE LOOKING A LITTLE DOPEY.
YOU WORK
WITH THE ELEMENTS.
WITH THE RAIN.
YOU WORK WITH
THE WIND.
YOU GAVE
A LOT OF ENERGY,
AND YOU GAVE IT
A LOT OF HEART,
AND IT DIDN'T COME TOGETHER
COMPLETELY FOR YOU.
MICHELLE.
YOU KNOW, MICHELLE,
I REALLY LIKE YOU.
THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT YOU,
YOU REMIND ME A LOT
OF WHO I AM IN THE WORLD.
SO YOU THINK
YOU'RE A 7-FOOT-TALL BLONDE?
IN MY DREAMS,
I AM, YEAH.
HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
OH!
NICE!
THIS PHOTO FROM A DISTANCE,
IT'S GORGEOUS,
THE BODY POSITION,
BUT CLOSE-UP,
IT LOOKS LIKE
CARRIE AT THE END OF THE MOVIE
WHEN SHE KILLED
EVERYONE.
I MEAN,
IT'S REALLY BAD.
GO ON OUT OF HERE NOW,
GO ON NOW.
GET ON OUT
OF HERE.
TATIANA.
I DON'T LIKE THE LITTLE
PRETTY GIRL NEXT DOOR,
PEKINGESE, PUNCHED LOOK
IN THE FACE.
TATIANA HAS EVERYTHING
IT TAKES TO GET MOST GUYS GOING.
KAHLEN.
SHE'S DEFINITELY SELLING
SOMETHING IN THIS SHOT.
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS,
BUT IT'S SELLING.
BRITTANY.
I THINK
SHE'S COOL.
SHE'S INTERESTING.
SHE'S LOUD,
AND SHE'S OBNOXIOUS.
THIS PHOTO
IS AMAZING.
IT LOOKS LIKE AN OLD, EARLY
HERB RITTS PHOTO.
TIFFANY.
SHE JUST LOOKS
SCARED.
SHE LOOKS
KIND OF, "OOH!"
VERY SCARY WHEN YOU LOOK
UP CLOSE AT HER FACE.
SCARED OR SCARY?
BOTH.
KEENYAH.
I DON'T THINK
THIS WAS KEENYAH'S BEST DAY.
SHE DIDN'T
SELL IT, BABY.
SHE LOOKED STIFF.
IT'S NOT GREAT.
SHE CAN DO BETTER
THAN THIS.
CHRISTINA.
I LIKE
THE LITTLE MOUTH.
I LIKE THE BIG,
BUGGY EYES,
AND I LIKE THAT WASPY, YANKEE
KIND OF FEELING SHE'S GOT.
WHEN SHE BROKE DOWN,
I SAW A HUMAN BEING.
BEFORE THAT,
I JUST SAW THIS ICE PRINCESS.
MICHELLE.
MICHELLE,
MY LITTLE TOMBOY,
MY LITTLE TOMGIRL.
MY PROBLEM WITH MICHELLE
IS THE TWITCHES, THE FISTS.
SOMETHING ABOUT MICHELLE
JUST TUGS AT MY HEARTSTRINGS.
REBECCA.
REBECCA REMINDS ME OF
THOSE GREAT STOCK RUNWAY MODELS.
SHE'S JUST GOOD TO HAVE
AT AN AGENCY TO MAKE MONEY,
BUT SHE'S NOT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOU DON'T KNOW
THAT YET.
I DON'T
KNOW THAT YET.
LLUVY.
SHE JUST LOOKS LIKE
A WET CHIHUAHUA ON AN ESPRESSO.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT HER
THAT IS MESMERIZING.
I THINK LLUVY HAS THE FACE
TO BE A STAR,
BUT IF YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THAT FACE...
NAIMA.
NAIMA WITH HER
BEAUTIFUL CREAMY VOICE.
HER VOICE
IS REALLY COOL.
IT GOES TO THE INDIVIDUAL,
WHETHER YOU'RE A WORKING MOTHER,
A YOUNG GIRL...
BUT SHE'S GOT
THE BEST BODY HERE.
SHE NEEDS TO LOSE
5 TO 10 POUNDS,
AND I HATE
TO SAY IT--
THEY'RE ALL FAT!
THE ENTIRE ROOM
IS FAT.
I'M FAT--
YOU'RE ALL FAT.
I HAVE TEN BEAUTIFUL WOMEN
THAT STAND IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE NINE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE NINE OF YOU
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
KAHLEN.
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
BRITTANY.
WE LOVE
YOUR PERSONALITY,
JUST LEARN TO REEL IT IN
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
NAIMA.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
CHRISTINA.
IT'S LIKE,
"I'M GONNA SMILE NOW,
"LET ME PUT A SMILE
ON MY FACE."
YOU WERE
THE MOST ENDEARING TONIGHT
AND SHOWED
SOME HUMANITY.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
MICHELLE.
YOU'RE ONE-OF-A-KIND,
QUIRKY, OFFBEAT,
AND THAT'S WHY YOU CONTINUE
FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
BECAUSE
YOU'RE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TATIANA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
TIFFANY.
THANKS.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL...
KEENYAH.
KEENYAH, YOU'RE USUALLY
AT THE HEAD OF THE PACK,
BUT TONIGHT
YOU WERE LUKEWARM.
IT IS UP TO YOU TO PUSH YOURSELF
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
WILL LLUVY AND REBECCA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS ONE PHOTO
REPRESENTS THE GIRL
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE GIRL THAT
I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR LOFT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
THE REASON THAT THE TWO OF YOU
STAND BEFORE ME TONIGHT
IS BECAUSE
FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
YOUR CRITIQUE
IS THE SAME.
FOR REBECCA,
IT'S BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT SAFE, BORING.
TOP MODELS
AREN'T BORING.
THEY'RE EDGY.
THEY'RE
INTERESTING.
LLUVY, YOU HAVE
ALL THE POTENTIAL IN THE WORLD,
BUT FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
YOUR PICTURES SAY OTHERWISE.
I BELIEVE THAT
YOU HAVE SO MUCH POTENTIAL.
I THINK THE BOTH OF YOU HAVE HAD
THE WEAKEST PROGRESSION.
BOTH OF YOU HIT
ON ONE PHOTO SHOOT,
BUT TO BE ON THE ROAD
TO BEING A TOP MODEL
IS ABOUT MORE THAN
JUST HITTING IT ONCE,
AND ONE OF YOU IS GONNA GET
A CHANCE TO HIT IT AGAIN.
REBECCA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANKS, LLUVY.
I'M SO LOST
RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
(sniffling)
I-- THIS BEING A MODEL HAS BEEN
MY DREAM SINCE I WAS 3.
I AM NOT THE "COVER GIRL" GIRL,
YOU KNOW?
BUT I KNOW
I'M STRANGELY BEAUTIFUL.
MAYBE I'M TOO REALISTIC
FOR THIS.
MY HEAD'S NOT
IN THE CLOUDS.
CAREER-WISE, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
I WANT YOU
TO MASTER COCKNEY.
(imitates Cockney accent)
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
DO YOU WANT
A GO?
(imitates Cockney accent)
IF YOU WANT
A GO?
(imitates Cockney accent)
IF YOU WANT A GO, GO.
A TOUGH ACTING LESSON
LEADS UP TO THE GIRLS'
MOST DARING PHOTO SHOOT...
I ALREADY FEEL
THE HEART GOING.
OH, MY GOD!
DON'T BE AFRAID
OF HIM.
BRING YOUR CHIN UP,
TIFFANY,
BRING YOUR CHIN UP!
FOR REAL, THAT WAS HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT.
AT ELIMINATIONS, ONE MODEL
SENDS ME OVER THE EDGE.
BE QUIET!